il ya plusieurs façons d'accommoder le
gras doubles toutes sont excellentes
mais voici comment le prépare à lyon
ville gastronomique réputé comme vous le
savez pour 2 personnes 500 g de gras
doubles épais et bien et cuits et couper
en lanières
on dirait presque des la zale
[Musique]
ce gras doubles va rejoindre dans la
poêle et dans du beurre bien chaud un
oignon émincé
[Musique]
il rit sol de tous les côtés et le chef
le prends même pour une crêpe
[Musique]
m
un coup de main à attraper pour lui
donner saveurs parfums et couleurs
ajouté successivement une belle tomate
concassée 2 gousses d'ail écrasées une
grosse main cette persil haché du sel
[Musique]
du poivre nous et enfin 10 centilitres
de vin blanc sec
[Musique]
après quelques minutes de cuisson le
mélange qui doit rester moelleux et
versez dans un peur
[Musique]
il est saupoudrer de chapelure et glissé
au floor il va prendre une belle teinte
dorée
[Musique]
ce plat se sert très chaud c'est
indispensable et les on vous conseille
d'en apprécier la saveur en buvant à
beaujolais de l'année
[Musique]